vers pur éco nature bio clean plus que
jamais les fabricants de nettoyeurs et
de savon à vaisselle évoque la
naturalité la santé et l'environnement
pour nous vendre leurs produits
mais sont ils vraiment écologique voilà
on a l'exemple des nouvelles type de
tendance est à dire vraiment des design
beaucoup plus épuré on avance un produit
qui est naturel donc long à 89 9 %
naturel donc vraiment on veut quasiment
aller vers le 100% naturels les produits
ce qu'on appelle nous les clean label
vous n'avez pas de label qui est mis en
avant devant le produit est derrière
vous allez avoir des labels qui touche
aujourd'hui plus les consommateurs c'est
à dire la question du fabriqués
localement et la question qu'il n'ya pas
cruauté animale
excédé gagnent sur ce produit là on n'a
pas la garantie est un produit 99 9 %
naturel parce qu'il n'ya pas de
certification qui existe sur cet élément
alors quand je regarde ce produit et je
vois la couleur verte
je vois une plante qui fait appel à la
naturalité
je vois en énorme le mot green donc à
première vue je me dis mais oui c'est un
produit naturel c'est sûr on me dit
qu'il est extraordinairement puissants
et dérivées de sources naturelles à 95%
mais quand je regarde je ne vois pas de
label officiel
il n'est pas fait mention de la
biodégradabilité on est aujourd'hui de
plus en plus dans ce qu'on appelle du
greenwashing d'exécution c'est à dire
que on donne une impression de nature
par certainteed images par certains
types d'arguments par certains types de
deux mots qui sont utilisés on ne ment
pas forcément consommateurs on essaye de
le mettre dans une image plus celle plus
naturel pour essayer de séduire
quand je regarde ce produit déjà je vois
l'image d'un beau petits canetons et en
plus on me dit que ce produit est de la
faune donc à première vue je me dis que
c'est un produit qui est bon
environnementalement parlant
et puis quand je retourne le produit
j'ai pas vraiment beaucoup
d'informations parce que je n'ai ni de
labels officiels
tant de déclarations d'auto déclaration
qui pourrait me dire en quoi ce produit
est bon pour l'environnement ou pour ma
santé
alors il ya effectivement deux grands
types d'étiquetage donc l'étiquetage de
type 1 qui va être lui labellisés par
des parties prenantes externes à
l'entreprise
on a par exemple écologo qui est une
certification environnementale
puis l'éco étiquetage de type 2 donc là
on va parler plus d'autos déclarations
faites par les entreprises donc ça peut
être vérifié par des parties tierces ou
pas donc là on n'a pas forcément de
garantie pour le consommateur
chose certaine la tendance écologique
fait vente
ce marché est en très forte expansion
alors une fois que tout est à prouver
maintenant on peut remplir des
compagnies comme bio verts temps de
répondre à cette demande croissante
leurs produits sont certifiés écologo
qui est la seule certification
écologique reconnue au canada au fait
écolo gaulle à lui qu'est ce qui va vous
dis là ils vont était juste là pour
certifier la qualité d'un produit que se
produit un lorsqu'ils retournent dans
l'environnement
il ne cause aucun problème de lorsqu'il
est utilisé par le consommateur
il est créé par des problèmes toxiques
sur le corps humain et ensuite les
critères d'affiliation écologo sont
extrêmement élevés c'est une
certification ou il ya vraiment un
cahier des charges avec une
normalisation c'est la norme souvent les
normes ce qu'on appelle les normes iso
et avec un organisme indépendant qui
avait atteint le mans regarder le cycle
de vie du produit sur l'impact
environnemental lorsqu'on est dans les
questions de écologo mais je pense que
vous avez besoin de quelque chose qui
vous garantit que ce produit respecte
exactement ce qui est écrit d'où la
notion d'éco logo cessa écologo mais à
défaut de voir cette certification ci
s'est inscrit biodégradables est-ce que
c'est aussi sécuritaire je vous dirais
non c'est pas parce qu'un produit est
biodégradable qui les écolos bout pas du
tout il est biodégradable mais il n'est
pas écologique passé quand on dit
écologique c'est a dit qu'il va
retourner dans l'environnement il ne
laisse aucun effet néfaste
alors je peux retourner dans
l'environnement mais j'écris beaucoup de
dommages après à l'heure actuelle seuls
20% des produits de nettoyage sur le
marché répond aux normes déco logo pour
les 80 % qui restent
comment s'y retrouver
alors aujourd'hui c'est sûr que c'est
très complexe parce que il faut que le
consommateur entre guillemets regarde
les ingrédients connaissent la liste
d'ingrédients - iliad ingrédients plus
on peut espérer qu'il ya d'impact sur
l'environnement et d'impact sur la santé
la problématique c'est qu'il faut
connaître les ingrédients